le parti communiste français aux
législatives 2017 il pesé 1,20 % des
voix soit 12 députés
on en oublierait presque que fut un
temps le pcf était le premier parti de
france
[Musique]
retour en 1945 à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale les élections
législatives de 1945 récompense
l'engagement du pcf dont la résistance
avec 27% des voix et 159 sièges à
l'assemblée
les communistes sont leaders il devance
tout juste le mouvement républicain
populaire 150 sièges et le parti
socialiste avec 146 sièges
côté gouvernement les ministres
communistes emmenés des chantiers
sociaux retraites chômage allocations
familiales mais surtout les débuts de la
sécurité sociale le parti communiste au
sommet de sa gloire pour mesurer sa
popularité
il n'y a qu'à voir l'engouement à la
fête de l'huma édition 1945
on n'a jamais vu tant demande à la fois
popularité qui persistent dans les urnes
aux législatives le pcf est haut plus
fort en 1946 avec 28 % avant de se
stabiliser autour des 20% jusqu'en 1962
mais cette année 62 le pcf est dépassé
par l'alliance gaulliste eu des airs eu
d'été en 1965 à leur tour les
communistes tentent la stratégie de
l'union
le comité central du parti communiste
français a décidé unanimement de
soutenir la candidature de françois
mitterrand en tant que candidat d'union
de tous les partis de gauche l'alliance
des partis de gauche se concrétise cette
ampleur
ces deux programmes communs en 1972 en
s'alliant au ps leader de l'union
le pcf s'efface derrière les socialistes
qui pour la première fois dépasse les
communistes dans les urnes
[Musique]